Trascrizione: Anna M
Revisore: Federico MINELLE
[Musica]
[Applausi]
Ho amato la natura fin da piccolo.
I miei ricordi vanno da quando
guardavo il mondo dall'alto
dallo zaino di mio papà
durante le escursioni estive in montagna
e poi dal basso del mio metro e qualcosa
non appena ho imparato a camminare
e riconoscere cosa fosse un sentiero.
Mio padre è fotografo naturalista,
mi ha insegnato ad osservare
ed a farmi domande.
La farfalla che si posava sulla mia mano,
gli stambecchi maschi in lotta
nella nebbia autunnale,
i minerali che brillavano al sole.
Pian piano sono diventati dei compagni
che ritrovavo tutte le estati.
Sulla riva di questi laghetti alpini
ho dato il mio primo bacio
e molti dei viaggi immaginari
che facevo da adolescente
avevano luogo in montagna,
erano ambientati lì.
Salire verso l'alto,
scoprire nuovi sentieri
era ogni volta un avventura,
ma anche qualcosa che
mi faceva sentire a casa.
Estate dopo estate,
cercare stelle cadenti nel cielo notturno
è una sana passione per guerre stellari.
Mi ha fatto venir voglia di
conoscere meglio l'universo.
Allora ho comprato un libro,
che spiegava le stelle, le costellazioni
e leggevo di nebulose di
polvere che creavano pianeti
e particelle in viaggio fin
dall'origine dell'universo,
di fusione nucleare al centro del sole.
Tutto aumentava il mio senso
di meraviglia.
Spazi e tempi immensi erano
a portata di un semplice binocolo, anzi
a volte li potevo percepire
anche ad occhio nudo,
come quando trovavo
la galassia di Andromeda
nel cielo
e mi accorgevo di stare a guardare
indietro nel tempo
di due milioni di anni
tanto ci aveva messo la luce
ad arrivare ai miei occhi.
O quando vedevo
il centro della nostra galassia:
la Via Lattea
e mi accorgevo che in fondo,
io e lei
eravamo fatti praticamente
degli stessi elementi.
A scuola non ero molto bravo in fisica:
sapevo fare bene i conti,
ma dimostrare i teoremi
non era il mio pane,
però il mio professore di
scienze era un laureato
in scienze forestali,
una disciplina che non
sapevo neanche esistesse.
Mi spiegò che questa materia
insegnava non solo
a conoscere la natura,
ma anche a lavorare insieme
a lei per il bene della Società.
Sembrava un lavoro
a contatto con l'ambiente,
in più mi affascinava
la prospettiva di mettere
un po' le mani in pasta,
anzichè limitarmi ad uno
studio da spettatore.
Così era deciso:
l'estate della maturità mi iscrissi
a Scienze Forestali.
Negli anni dell'università
continuavo ad andare in montagna,
ma l'attenzione si spostava ora sul bosco
che fino ad allora consideravo uno sfondo
oppure un noioso intermezzo
da superare il più in fretta possibile
per arrivare un po' più in alto.
Ora invece imparavo a
riconoscere gli alberi,
a chiamarli per nome,
a sapere che ciascuno ha i suoi gusti
in fatto di luce, di acqua,
di suolo dove crescere.
Soprattutto imparavo che
tutte le cose in natura
sono collegate
anche su distanze e tempi
che sembrano impossibili da colmare.
È un po' come i nostri atomi,
sono stati forgiati
nel nucleo delle stelle
miliardi di anni fa,
allo stesso modo le foreste
portano in sé la traccia di
eventi lontani
nel tempo e nello spazio.
Prendiamo gli anelli di
accrescimento annuali degli alberi:
negli anelli noi possiamo leggere
non solo l'età delle piante,
ma anche la pioggia,
il caldo, il freddo del passato
registrati nell'ampiezza
di ciascun anello.
Così che leggendo oggi
questi diari naturali
siamo in grado di ricostruire
il clima di decenni
o centinaia di anni fa
e capire come stia cambiando.
Per esempio:
quasi tutti gli alberi della terra
si ricordano
della più grande eruzione
vulcanica registrata in tempi storici
quella del vulcano Tambora,
in Indonesia
nel 1815.
In poco meno di un anno
la cenere fece il giro della Terra
si disperse in tutta l'atmosfera
causando una stagione
così fredda e umida
che il 1816
venne ricordato come l'anno senza estate.
Quell'anno gli alberi crebbero molto meno
e ancora oggi troviamo la
traccia di questa eruzione
nell'anello di accrescimento del 1816
improvvisamente più stretto
di tutti gli altri.
Molte altre cose accaddero
in quell'anno senza estate:
gli eserciti di Napoleone
si impanatarono nel terreno
inaspettatamente zuppo a Waterloo;
nella campagna svizzera
un gruppo di amici scrittori
fu costretto a passare gran
parte dell'estate al chiuso,
tra di loro, una dicianovenne
Mary Shelley
scrisse Frankestein;
i tramonti nei cieli del nord Europa
si colorarono di rosso
a causa della cenere vulcanica
che era ancora dispersa nell'aria,
come vediamo ancora oggi
nel "L'urlo" di Munch.
Ecco, ogni volta che
guarderete questo quadro
da oggi in poi
potrete percepire,
quanto siamo connessi
a tutto quello che avviene sul Pianeta.
Anche se oggi non ce ne
accorgiamo, pure le foreste
ci legano alla terra
e rendono possibile la vita.
Più di un miliardo di persone nel mondo
dipende dalle foreste per
bere acqua pulita.
Gli alberi inoltre
trattengono il terreno con le radici,
intercettano la pioggia
con le foglie,
la fanno infiltrare lentamente nel suolo
con il loro humus,
diminuendo così la velocità del deflusso
e proteggendo chi abita a valle
da frane ed alluvioni.
Il carbonio, che gli alberi assorbono
grazie alla fotosintesi, viene
sottratto all'atmosfera
e questo ci aiuta nella lotta ai
cambiamenti climatici,
che senza le foreste sarebbero
del 30% più intensi.
L'assorbimento di carbonio
poi può essere prolungato
se facciamo rivivere gli alberi
nel loro legno:
le travi del tetto di alcune
malghe [alpeggi], baite di montagna
ci dimostrano che il legno può
trattenere carbonio
al suo interno
per decine o centinaia di anni
e oggi l'edilizia in legno sta
vivendo una nuova primavera.
Gli architetti di tutto il mondo
si sfidano
a costruire edifici in legno
sempre più alti, di design,
grazie alle nuove opportunità
offerte dal Mass Timber, dal XLam.
In fondo il legno
che usiamo tutti i giorni
negli oggetti di casa nostra,
ci connette a tutta la Terra,
all'aria che è servita
per far crescere gli alberi
all'acqua e al suolo
che li hanno nutriti,
alle mani e alla fantasia di chi
li ha lavorati per noi.
Purtroppo in Italia
quando usiamo il legno
ci connettiamo spesso
ad ingiustizie ambientali o sociali.
Nonostante le nostre foreste
siano in aumento,
quasi l'80% del legno che utilizziamo
proviene dall'estero
e di questo un quinto
da foreste che sono tagliate
in modo illegale
o insostenibile,
come negli stati del Sud America
o dell'Europa dell'est.
Le foreste sono un ecosistema delicato:
se non sono gestite nel modo corretto
rischiano di perdersi,
e con loro la qualità della vita,
di chi dalle foreste dipende
per acqua, cibo, lavoro.
Una parte dei migranti climatici
che oggi sono costretti a spostarsi
in ampie parti del mondo
sono spinti a partire dalla deforestazione
e dagli effetti che la deforestazione ha
sulla sicurezza alimentare,
sull'accesso all'acqua
e sulla salute.
Esistono invece strategie per
aumentare l'uso del legno
in modo sostenibile dalle nostre foreste,
evitando gli impatti a lunga distanza
e garantendo al tempo stesso
la conservazione
della loro biodiversità
e della funzione di protezione del suolo.
Per esempio: si tratta di
scegliere le piante da tagliare
in modo di lasciare spazio e
luce alle nuove piantine
che nel frattempo si saranno
sviluppate dai semi
che gli alberi intorno hanno
disperso nell'ambiente
e che crescendo
garantiranno che la foresta
nel suo complesso
continui a prosperare.
Scegliere quali piante
tagliare, quali lasciare,
quali foreste possono darci
legno in modo sostenibile
e quali invece è prioritario
gestire e conservare
per la loro diversità,
è il compito della
pianificazione forestale.
Un compito che deve impostare oggi
quello che vogliamo che
accada tra 50 o 100 anni.
Perchè la lentezza con cui
crescono le foreste
ci obbliga a connetterci
con una percezione del tempo
radicalmente diversa dalla nostra.
Guardando al futuro poi
non possiamo dimenticare
i cambiamenti climatici.
Oggi l'aumento di temperatura, di siccità
causa ondate di mortalità
nelle foreste di tutto il mondo.
Può propagare e facilitare
la propagazione di incendi molto vasti
come abbiamo visto in Italia
nell'estate del 2017
e causare la drastica riduzione
della superficie occupata da
alcune specie forestali
come già stiamo osservando nelle Alpi.
In più, un'atmosfera più energetica
significa una maggiore probabilità
che si verifichino alucni eventi estremi
come gli schianti provocati dal vento
che si sono verificati in Trentino,
in Friuli, in Veneto.
Un fenomeno che non ha
precedenti storici in Italia.
Questi cambiamenti sono molto più veloci
della capacità delle piante
di evolversi e di adattarsi,
ma forse possiamo aiutare gli
alberi ad attraversarli,
ad esempio facendoli crescere
in modo che resistano
un po' di più al vento
o assicurandoci che esista
una giovane generazione di piantine
pronta a partire in caso di
catastrofe naturale.
Prendiamo per esempio
un piccolo seme di faggio.
Il faggio è una specie un po' speciale,
contrariamente alla maggior
parte delle piante
che si riproducono ogni anno,
come ci aspetteremmo da un
organismo che è interessato
a diffondersi, a colonizzare
l'ambiente che lo circonda,
il faggio invece funziona
ad intermittenza.
In alcuni anni produce moltissimo seme,
in altri poco o nessuno.
La cosa straordinaria
è che questa variabilità è
sincronizzata puntualmente
tra albero e albero,
tra foresta e foresta
anche su grandi distanze
come tra le faggete tra le Alpi
e quelle della Foresta Nera in Germania.
Con il nostro team di ricerca
abbiamo scoperto che questa variabilità
in realtà è causata da una
ben precisa sequenza climatica.
È necessaria prima un estate
fresca ed umida
per aumentare la disponibilità
di sostanze nutritive nel terreno
e subito dopo una calda e secca,
per spingere le piante e le gemme
a produrre fiori, anzichè foglie.
Se le sostanze nutritive si
sono accumulate,
la fioritura avverrà in massa
e con essa la produzione
di frutti e di semi.
Questa sequenza inoltre
è legata ai cicli dell'attività solare.
Quando il sole è più attivo
il clima sulla terra è
un po' più variabile,
discontinuo, imprevedibile.
Così è più probabile che si
susseguano stagioni
molto diverse tra di loro,
come nel caso di una fredda ed umida
e di una calda e secca subito dopo.
Questo fenomeno
ha ripercussioni su tutti gli ecosistemi,
anzitutto sul numero di
germogli e di piantine
che possono rappresentare
il futuro della foresta,
soprattutto se queste annate
di iper-produzione di seme
si verificano subito dopo un incendio,
da cui la foresta può quindi
riprendersi molto più facilmente.
E poi a cascata, con effetti
sempre più ampi
sul numero dei mammiferi che
si nutrono di quei semi,
sui parassiti che trasportano,
come le zecche per esempio
o il loro ospite un po' sgradevole:
il batterio del morbo di lyme.
O ancora, sulle concentrazioni dei pollini
che sono prodotti da quei fiori
e che possono causare
un picco nelle allergie.
Ecco, i cicli dei semi di faggio
ci raccontano le storie delle connessioni
che attraversano la natura,
dal seme al sole,
fino ad arrivare a noi.
Quasi a rispecchiare lo stesso legame
che accomuna i nostri atomi
con quello che avviene
nel nucleo delle stelle.
Quando muovevo i primi passi
nelle alpi piemontesi
non avrei mai immaginato
di diventare uno scienziato.
A dir la verità volevo fare il contadino,
come suggerisce il significato
originale del mio nome:
Giorgio,
ma guardavo l'ambiente che mi circondava,
mi lasciavo meravigliare
dagli alberi, dalle farfalle,
dai cieli stellati
e capivo che tutte le cose
erano in qualche modo
collegate tra di loro.
Una rete di relazioni in cui
mi sentivo a casa,
piccolo forse
ma non insignificante.
Studiare le foreste continua
a raccontarmi le storie
delle relazioni che percorrono
gli ecosistemi
anche a grandissima distanza.
Un fenomeno affascinante
di cui posso addirittura farmi canale,
raccontando a voi oggi qui
di alberi e di legno,
di semi e di incendi
e aprendo una connesione
attraverso cui ciascuno di voi
possa sentirsi
parte integrante dell'ecosistema,
riconoscendosi al tempo stesso
una sua causa e un suo effetto.
Ce ne accorgiamo noi,
noi apparteniamo a queste relazioni
e gli alberi e il legno, come
grandi connettori,
legano la nostra vita
a quella di tante altre persone
sulla Terra
vicine e lontane
che sono venute o che verranno.
Piccole ma non insignificanti.
Tutt'uno col Pianeta.
Reti di relazioni con altri uomini.
Questo è quello che per me
significa vivere.
Grazie.
[Applausi]